[Musique]
ça ressemble à s'y méprendre à du
tableau pourtant le pinceau de françois
boiseau c'est son appareil depuis dix
ans il mêle ses deux passions la
photographie et l'aviation est donc en
faisant les deux mains ça fait faire des
photos de paysages de
le morceau de notre terre pour faire des
formes de tableau est arrivé à des
compositions qui soit agréable à
regarder donc qui sont ici pour être
partagé ce qui m'inspire c'est les lieux
où il ya des des formes
et des couleurs très spécifiques donc ça
peut être effectivement les bords de mer
ça peut être aussi les champs par
exemple en ce moment il ya les champs de
colza mais toujours une albers a fait
des trucs assez incroyable
ça peut être aussi
les forêts des vues aériennes de la
france le bassin d'arcachon la baie de
somme où les salines de guérande ou le
regard cherche le moindre détail
je me suis branché là dessus parce que
je trouve qu'on arrive quand même à une
forme de pureté dans l'ordre dans
l'image
[Musique]
que je retrouve essentiellement dans la
dans la photo aérienne que je peux
retrouver ailleurs aussi évidemment mais
là dans la photo aérienne il ya toujours
fort et à mesure que j'avançais que j'en
fais d'autres à chaque fois et se créent
de nouvelles images etc jamais jamais
terminé c'est ça aussi qui est
intéressant les clichés sont rassemblés
en mairie et à la médiathèque de
villepreux dix ans la tête dans les
nuages
à travers 120 photographies